[UPBEAT ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
- I PREFER TRADITIONAL PORN,
BUT IN A PINCH,
SORORITY RECRUITMENT VIDEOS
WILL DO.
SORORITIES ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE MAKING THESE,
BECAUSE LIKE ANY BUSINESS,
THEY HAVE TO TRICK NEW CUSTOMERS
INTO WASTING MONEY.
AND WHAT IS HIGHER EDUCATION
WITHOUT BLOWING GLITTER,
LAUGHING IN SLOW MOTION,
AND JUMPING IN SLOW MOTION?
I COULD WATCH THESE ALL DAY.
KAPPA DELTA AT MY ALMA MATER,
UCF, MADE ONE.
[UPBEAT ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
FIRST IN GRADES?
THAT'S SOMETHING
ONLY AN IDIOT WOULD SAY.
OF COURSE, NOBODY CAN OUT-IDIOT
THE UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA.
IT SHOULD COME AS NO SURPRISE
THAT A SORORITY FROM THE LAND
THAT INVENTED RACISM
MADE A VIDEO
THAT ONLY FEATURED WHITE GIRLS,
FLAUNTING HOW WHITE THEY ARE
BY WEARING ALL WHITE
WHILE DOING VERY WHITE THINGS,
LIKE SUCKING OFF POPSICLES
OR THE STAR FOOTBALL PLAYER.
[UPBEAT ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
WHITE POWER!
I MEAN GIRL POWER!
BUT WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN SORORITY LIFE ENDS?
I WANT THOSE BARELY LEGAL,
SMOKIN'-HOT CHICKS TO KNOW
THEY'LL ALWAYS HAVE A HOME
HERE AT "TOSH.0."
SO WHILE YOU'RE WAITING
TO GET SNATCHED UP
BY A WEALTHY HUSBAND,
WHY NOT MOVE TO L.A.
AND WORK FOR ME?
[UPBEAT ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
- ♪ I FEEL SO FREE ♪
♪ LET'S DO THIS AGAIN
AND AGAIN ♪
♪ IT'LL NEVER BE OVER ♪
♪ LET'S MAKE SURE
IT WON'T EVER END ♪
♪ FEEL SO FREE ♪
♪ ♪
♪ WE'RE LIVING LIFE TO NO END ♪
♪ NO END ♪
♪ ♪
♪ AND I FEEL SO FREE ♪
♪ LET'S MAKE SURE
IT WON'T EVER END ♪
♪ FEEL SO FREE ♪
♪ PROMISE
WE CAN DO THIS AGAIN ♪
♪ NEVER SAY IT'S OVER ♪
♪ WE'RE LIVING LIFE TO NO END ♪
- I'D LIKE TO REITERATE
THAT WE ARE NOT HIRING
ANY MORE DUMPY, MIDDLE-AGED,
IVY LEAGUE WHITE GUYS.
I'M ONLY LOOKING TO EMPLOY
GORGEOUS SORORITY GIRLS
FROM STATE SCHOOLS.
I CANNOT WAIT TO HAZE YOU ALL.